we'll take five suggestions then we have
all five then we'll do the wrap and
we'll
leave um let's get the first suggestion
i'm gonna come to
people in this enclave here what would
you like to hear a rep about dandruff
dendrophilia people who love trees yeah
yeah okay cool yeah okay everyone else
is like what language is that even
um dendrophilia people who love trees
are you a dendrophile
no where did you where did you come
across the world
no i just i'm just wondering what porn
site you go to that's the thing
dendrophiles.com dendrophilia people who
love trees
um people over here what would you like
a rap about
wait oh yes go grace the timing yes no i
have to leave the show
um what would you like a rap about
[Music]
epcot center the epcot center that is in
disney world
florida orlando yeah or it was
it's still there oh cool i only know
about that because i've watched a series
three or four of the americans
this plays a central role in it if you
like epcot you should watch the
americans it's very central to the plot
it's not um so the epcot center and
dendrophilia middle of the room and we
can include people at the back as well
from tables the bat don't feel like
you're kind of you know cut off from
this what would you like a rap about
auto fellatio okay cool autofellatio
another fancy word that means sucking
yourself off um
just in case you thought it was someone
who just walked around blowing cars
no auto fellatio not that um okay
people on this side of the room what
would you like a rap about
queen elizabeth queen elizabeth because
i've mentioned that that feels very kind
of like i've implanted that in use i'm
not going to take that
it's also a really common suggestion i
get people go ah the queen
um but you can have another girl or
someone else can
i i missed that and it sounded great
what was it
red brick walls how imaginative wow
that's great you could have said
anything in the world you were like
uh there's a wall behind him i'll say
that great dendrophilia the epcot center
red brick walls and autofellatio one
final suggestion this can come from
anywhere in the room
but make it good what did you say
all djs and what did someone else say
miami okay old djs in miami
i like it i i misheard miami i thought
you said maya
angelou and i was like oh my angela was
an old dj would be great
um so all djs in miami auto fellatio the
epcot center red brick walls and
dendrophilia
this lovely people um it's gonna be a
freestyle rap can we drop the beat good
sir
we'll just get kind of warmed up with
this this will be fun
i like that a lot of you were kind of
chuckling as if you thought it wasn't
gonna happen
as if i was gonna put the mic in the
stand and just walk away no it's a wrap
based on all those suggestions
um do not worry it won't be anywhere
near as atrociously embarrassingly
tokenly bad if you're expecting a
privately
uh middle-class white woman to be
awesome let's have some fun
start off get sillier than i ever did
before with the dendrophilia i'll be
walking in the little forest with gree
just on my own just me and these trees
i'll be walking up
dance around in the park and i say your
tree is your bite or your bark the worst
one i never even mind being funny then i
climb up the tree and i steal that honey
from the bees they
be get lost boss this tree and me on my
own just us
and i walk around and i grasp the trunk
i'm like old tree you're like a handsome
hunk i wanna rub my fingers
through your branches do you wanna [ __ ]
on the tree answers
just in a little wave of the boughs i
say we gotta get this
on now so i go one better like a
woodpecker put it in the trunk yeah run
i bring us both together and the tree
comes
at the same time as me i know that this
is not what you want
to see when you say dendrophilia you're
like oh my nan walks round in the middle
of the night
and goes oh this is really nice i'll
start looking at this
oak looking at this lush but that's okay
that's what she's saying maybe now i'm
so old she could be a dj
going on the little wheels of steel
she's like i'm 19 but i still reveal a
very good tasty music
oh let's drop the beat if you're in the
club yes then move your feet my name is
barbara hello there
take your mdma from your underwear have
fun when you're down even though i'm
elderly look at all this hydrate if
you're wrinkly totally fine don't expand
your brain
take ecstasy and do cocaine but not here
it's just a character an old dj damn i'm
having her i'm like can you play my
wedding
she's like sure but then she dies by the
time of the next year
sadly gotta take her replacement you
know this bro have you tried auto
fellatio have you gone there
have you been more flexible like i can't
even get erect at all
down there between my groin if i could
do this i could earn some coin going
on only fans i'm the only man to get my
head right into my underpants
like slamming the ball to the back of
your throat coming so loud screaming ah
like a goat that'd be screaming from the
taylor swift song or
fellatio how could it be that wrong
easier if you've got a long tongue
easier if you've got a long schlong
doesn't even matter
both of them can meet just be careful
don't do it in the view of the street
otherwise all the people look up their
reports say look at that window by the
red brick wall
guy outside you were waving your hand
you knew the round was coming up yes man
you and me build a hip-hop team be sick
standing right here look at those bricks
that one right by the comedian's head
it's really nice it's really red that's
what we want i can see the mortar
oh i should go home and kiss my door to
say what you want to be
what you want your job maybe be a
builder with a little hot if you don't
really understand the word that's it a
hot is what you use to carry loads of
bricks i know that cause i grew up
working class and my dad came home and
he'd raise a glass and say chris
today oh i worked hard went there to the
little brick builders yard
put them out the best of all and i put
up the red bricks and i made a wall but
have you seen this
don't be mistaken this isn't actually
brick this is a fake one
they just put that there last thing we
can do oh yes so would you remind the
truth what was the word that we needed
to do
there's only one left and i'm looking at
you anybody can help you can remind to
my brain
okay you're the guy who said it and you
didn't even know you're like what's this
guy doing in the show trying to ask me
yeah drop it like it's hot talk about
disney and the epcot
center for technology and the future if
you go in a space suit it'll suit you
built in the 80s by walt disney's
matey's saying oh everybody won't be
frustrated they'll stand in the queue
getting kind of wild saying i'm so glad
i came here with my little child
admittedly it kind of tapered off at the
end but there we go we did epcot for my
nerdish friend
[Applause]